my mother's dream was for us to go to
college and I think for a lot of
first-generation college students
college represents this opportunity not
just for us but for our whole families
to change the story of their lives
my name is Jamie Rojas I am from Costa
Rica and an international student here
at MIT my parents didn't go to college
my mom's a housekeeper my dad's a
construction worker me getting into
college was like a pretty big deal my
dad was a steel worker he didn't
graduate from high school my grandfather
had a grammar school education he was
also a steel worker my great-grandfather
was a steel worker and I grew up in an
area where it wasn't really expected
that people were gonna go to college my
parents they went to elementary school
and that's it they were very supportive
and they were always like people tell
you that getting into MIT is impossible
but we think that you can do it because
you're putting a lot of effort I sort of
went through a lot of the process on my
own just because my parents you know
hadn't gone through the process
themselves so they didn't really you
know they were there for me but they
couldn't provide a lot of advice feeling
about vacations taking tests like
sending in scores and like getting
recommendations for like it was a lot it
was a lot of things it took a lot of
figuring out and a lot of it was just
like I had to ask my teachers had to ask
family friends right when I went away to
this prep school my dad was working
temporarily as a janitor and when I said
I wanted to go away to this boarding
school he almost started to cry and he
said I don't want you to go cuz I'm
afraid you're gonna come back and look
down on me because I'm a janitor there
was this very brief stint like around my
sophomore year of high school where
first look second it was like am I going
to college like is that is that
something I should do like it was it was
that bad like it was the pointers like I
didn't know if I should go to college
after all of that effort I ended up
getting into MIT amazing just an
unbelievable feeling
I had always been a bright student so to
go to college and all of a sudden find
out that there were these things I
didn't know that I was supposed to know
in that everybody else in the classroom
had learned stuff that I had never
learned it was a humbling and
demoralizing experience that led me at
times to just retreat and think to
myself this is not the place for me
your family is typically almost counting
on you you know you've made them so
proud it's such a rare thing maybe you
know first one to go to college first
one to try this thing out and
particularly at a place like MIT it's
you know you don't want to disappoint
anyone but the last thing I wanted to do
was walk into a professor's office
insane you know I'm not following
something I don't know what's happening
I need help with that and says it took
me you know I think until the very end
of college to work up that kind of
courage for me College is you know then
make-it-or-break-it
thing it's it's not a there is no option
to change my mind my mother witnessed
her dream come true
her two kids heading off to college and
I think she's simultaneously worried and
was dreadfully afraid that college was
going to change us I feel like I belong
here after all I was here for just six
months and then I went to Costa Rica but
I wanted to come back when we came home
on the holidays we were under great
scrutiny everyone was looking at how we
talked and how we sat and what we ate
and how we behaved and what music we
listened to you know they had to figure
out what was happening to us whether or
not we still belonged when students move
away to go to elite schools there is a
real rupture that gets created with
families at home but their families are
coming from different backgrounds
and often time I think both the students
and the parents don't really know how to
address that and and those feelings get
buried a lot I think I am my family
support system once I graduate my mother
has always wanted to be in an airplane
my father has always wanted to have a
telescope in a few years I think I will
be able to make those dreams real I put
a lot of effort to change my life and I
would like to do something to change
theirs not just my parents also my
sister and hopefully everyone else in my
family and hopefully everyone else in
the country the very success of our
careers has made us sort of invisible
and you know I walk into a room now and
people see me as the head of the history
faculty but they don't see me as a guy
from Bedford Stuyvesant who you know had
a good chance of not even making it
through college I now have a much bigger
perspective of the world I now
understand many things that I I didn't
understand I was living in like a bubble
and I had no idea what was happening
outside that place so MIT has opened my
mind it's life-changing because it just
sort of opens up in a whole other world
of opportunities than I would have ever
had access to and I feel like an MIT
degree no matter what you study there
are lots of ways to apply it I want to
conclude by celebrating and thinking the
good people of this world but at the
same time honoring a most important
couple in my life
the couple in my story left Eastern
Europe in the late 1930s during one of
the darkest periods in its history and
found refuge in South America
this couple raised four sons under
extremely difficult circumstances but
raised them with principles with
integrity and values out of the goodness
of good people this couple escaped
direct catastrophe so today I want to
honor everyone who is struggling and
with dreams of a brighter future for
their children and to tell each of them
that there is hope because the youngest
son of the couple in my story eventually
became the 17th president of one of the
most remarkable educational institutions
the world has ever seen
many people have dreams like the one I
had but they feel like those dreams are
basically impossible to achieve so with
an MIT degree with a college degree I
think I will have the voice to show the
world that you can actually achieve your
dreams